non lo so perché i ragazzi moustakas
armida l'incipit per diventare un
mongoloide che io già non lo sia più
bella a tutti ragazzi e prevenuti questo
nuovo video sono farisei che non ci
siano tornati su ai ris ex veramente mia
mi ha lasciato il segno l'ultima volta
no perché ho giocato l'ultima volta che
ci ho giocato è stata l'esperienza più
fantastica che io abbia mai fatto perché
se è ripartito di qua era arrivato più
avanti cacciano le vasche ricadevano e
ci sono i morti un'altra volta
giustamente mi sono dimenticato tutti i
comandi non mi dicono più un cazzo asuka
che cosa se no va bene non era costata
volta non era così l'ultima volta a tua
sorella deve morire male io ho rifatto
start per riprendere la partita
dell'altra volta ma non so perché ci
sono state a sky che non era così
l'ultimo allora fermi un attimo cosa ho
fatto
ma fermi castrato tasto reso merito che
lo sai non te lo metti questo ragazzi
non chiedetevi come ho fatto perché non
lo so chi siamo dove eravamo l'altra
volta no perché non mi sembrava che
avesse agganciato i salvataggi potevo
incazzarmi giusto un pochettino megawat
che figata
civati può adesso adesso questa si metta
a nuotare cioè senza fine senza calcio
cosa questa soffoca cioè non mangiano
anche al respiratore ma ci sono i pesci
con la barba non ho ben presente che sta
andando un tasso ricaccio un tasto dello
premo perfetto adesso vi prego perché mi
sa che me la sono messa nel culo da solo
farei annotabili a ok se riuscissi a
fare non ce l'ho fatta a veloci ho
provato non ho capito un attimo perché
ci proviamo tutti calmi e che corpo tra
incazzarmi seriamente io ho battuto non
erano no che stanno sbagliando
scusate un attimo cioè voleva dire ho
battuto tirannosauro ci ho messo 40
minuti per farlo e adesso siamo
sott'acqua senza motivo fantastico
ragazzi non ha non ha un senso
però io scrivo tutto
che culo che botta di culo check point
ragazze devo fare qui non fermina tema
che qualcosa qua si alzano [ __ ] [ __ ]
non so cosa mi fa la spinta cazzo ma poi
comprarmi il fico d'india andare su un
altro e vabbè ma impossibile ci vuole un
sottomarino a propulsione per superare
quel punto maledizione io riuscissi a ma
devo tipo stare attaccato qua sopra
si ok mio dio mezz'ora per capire se la
cella abbiamo provato prima era andato
troppo di sotto meno male allora ok no
no sì no no no no tu sei zocco tu sei
[ __ ] ma non ci voglio mai credere ma
non ci vuole una moglie di sciuscià
all'improvviso proprio che cioè stesso
sommesso non so quanto sei fermo perché
arrivano a pedata ragazzi mi ha rotto il
cazzo mia rock giuro che mi mimì mi
girano le palle non è possibile ma
testata leggere io l'ho vista solo da
materazzi cioè da patriti da allora i
[ __ ]
ok io donna sexy in costume pretendo di
passare grazie molto gentile ok non si
può fare sa parte
sentite allora un attimo che non è
posato sopra [ __ ] son riuscito anche
a mettere in pausa prima di mori giusto
per cose per godermi la morte come si
deve ma poi pupo almeno tutto tutto
quanto è proprio il fatto che ci ho
messo 80 minuti a fare quel pezzo che è
una cosa un po strana
cioè non è possibile che no no no no no
no no no beh allora 7 stronzi anche voi
questa parte giu dio mio sì che culo che
culo
ho vinto o rito basta basta ragazzi io
presidente degli stati uniti subito non
ho capito neanche che cazzo ha fatto
però non mi piace il fatto che ci sia la
bandiera allontana se faccio così no no
so già che me la prendo ne ragazzino io
so che sto per incazzarmi è una cosa che
so già prevedo il futuro proprio dalla
cammina attimo piano io di qui salto su
verona di merda cosa vuoi vuoi da me
dalla mia vita guida sono i partito di
grazie a dio sono il partito di quando
perché potevo incazzarmi né che devo
tornare giorni si può tornare anche giù
e allora qual è il senso sono stato
stuprato a farmi atti che prevede io se
vado qui sotto
errani mi guardano e senza che si vede
cosa succede muoio veramente mi hanno
stuprato non lo facciamo finta di niente
puoi morire aiuto santelli sulla testa
vabbè allora il senso è dimenticato le
chiavi a casa deve tartassare i maroni
anche se no no ma che cazzo che adesso
tornerà indietro credo adesso non tafi
che non toccano torni indietro lurida ok
veloce per ora
ok ce l'abbiamo ma dorati deve morire
proprio la famiglia come cazzo vuoi far
la sua parte non studia ma forse non
fermi un attimo
adesso si veloce però brava brava ok ho
vinto se mi sembra impossibile questa
cosa perché sa soltanto fare più veloce
mi fa strano ma va bene così cos'è lo
schivata subito [ __ ] subito stavolta
non lo preme il bottone ci ha pensato
alla sita a prenderlo fantastico
ascolterò città che cagli le uova
fresche dal culo se infatti cazzi tuoi
un pochettino brava ok mo e mini creeper
ma perché
ci sono cose non fermi nati con questi
salgono io devo saltare
ok no il bello è che faccio ste figure
di merda ma non dettaglio perché devono
essere documentate ste cose devo saltare
la sola testa di uno di sea stronzi si
ok allora era più semplice di quanto
pensassi sto coso non lo tocco la prima
cadevano delle pedane adesso non più
calandra ok adesso domandare qua devo
tornare ma perché va perché il gioco è
fatto apposta per fare incazzare le
persone più calme tipo boni o di sicuro
mi fai partire neanche qui c'è veramente
regalino che cazzo e do passare la vita
a giocare a sta roba perché l'ho trovata
su steam no no mio a doha doppia che
culo ok ok adesso adesso non allora
sembra in pokémon lo schifo dello schifo
ma [ __ ] ok ok ok perfetto
adesso non voglio rotture di palle però
il salto per sicurezza perché so già che
finisce male e lo sapevo lo sapevi
morisse tutta la famiglia per tanto lo
sapevo perché di parto da qui ok ok
calmi e lo stick vi giuro che le sole
cose prima che succedono però moglie lo
stesso che poi ha già fatto un livello
comunque ci sono
sono passi avanti piangiamo messo dei
secoli ok per una volta che ho
controllato sui cibi anonimi ragazzina
l'ho capita stava beh c'era un suicida
sma un popolo ranger però vabbè c'è una
cag a quando quando salto c'è una cag a
quando cago non sono quei cosi fermi
merda andrà grazie grazie
certo da marzo ito le parole per
descrivere il tetro yard ma come fai a
non saper fare un salto sono delle
palline ok ok nuovo e cosa che mi dà una
mano c'è il suo gioco perché muove si fa
a fare sta parte ok c'è il [ __ ]
checkpoint calming nota ucciso non
dovevo cadere lì perfetto porca [ __ ]
sarà mezz'ora buona che sono su sto
punto rega quindi o ci capiamo o ci
capiamo perché non è possibile perchè
capitino fermi attimo premi quella merda
lanciata che fai
adra la [ __ ] si fermava perchè si
rompe sì sì ma mi sono fatta perché mi
hai lasciato il gioco un anno si è
ridotta icona come cazzo si fermi un
attimo
ok ci siamo di gol non so perché essere
ridotte con al gioco ma mi ha fatto
prendere un infarto e mi sarei incazzato
tanto mezz'ora per fare sta merda o
princè allora io non mi dico lo skeet
cos'è sta roba
ma questo sì bell'amico via dalla
camminassimo io vado a prendere sta roba
ok tela lancio addosso proprio non l'ho
mai perché figura di cosa fa ancora ma
[ __ ] capo indiano a dare a parte gli
scherzi porta l'aquilano ammazzarlo
prima ho capito no no no a madonna 6
pezzo di merda pro per un attimo ho
creduto di aver vinto ma se fosse un
fenomeno a sti giochi non la farei tutti
sti tentati che bottigliate no [ __ ]
mi sono fatto implodere donna si ok di
morire di morire no si si io l'ho preso
veramente convintissimo però mancato al
punto forse non lo prendo invece sì ho
vinto ho vinto e mi fai mi fai scherzi
le botte che affaccia in via carmine
ragazzi è stato sono sudato sudato non
ci voglio veramente è assurdo giuro che
è assurdo cos'è sto schifo per un attimo
ho pensato che avresti c'è tutto che non
saresti mai arrivato fino qui quindi ora
combattiamo e chiara da ragazzini lei e
per non ci fosse concludere che
l'episodio il 3 2 finale nel prossimo
episodio ragazzi io per ora concludo
picon casa il video è piaciuto una
setacciando momento mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook e come non i video
tratte nella descrizione se volessi
discrete noi ci mettiamo il prossimo
vito e ragazzi